my talk of the table we're talking poet
amanda gorman know her love her you know
she's having a very ginormous year
we the successors of a country and the
time were a skinny black girl descended
from slaves and raised by a single
mother can dream
of becoming president
only to find herself reciting for one
wow i just love how she speaks you all
remember this making history as the
country's youngest poet to be featured
at a presidential inauguration and when
she delivered the super bowl's first
ever pre-game poem remember that that
was only the beginning for this 23 year
old superstar since then gorman has
appeared on the cover of time magazine
and variety just to name a few there she
is on glamour she's partnered with estee
lauder estee lauder and signed with img
models this morning she releases her
third book this year
it's called call us what we carry we
spoke with amanda gorman at the noya
house co-working space inside the
historic bradbury building it's a
beautiful place in downtown los angeles
when you look back over the course of
the year what has it been like for you
oh that's such a good question and it's
also i think a really difficult one to
answer
most of the year it felt like i was um
kind of shot out of a cannon and trying
to fly high
i was wondering if you felt like you
were on a rocket i actually wondered
that absolutely and i think one of the
scary things about being on a rocket is
you sometimes feel like the higher you
climb the harder you'll fall and so for
a lot of the year it was i think also
frightening and terrifying of could i
live up to this expectation could i live
up to this image an idea that people had
kind of made of me many would say amanda
gorman is exceeding expectations amanda
gorman amanda gorman amanda
everybody knows her name
how do you process that oh i'm not even
sure if i can process it i'm like a
macbook pro with a spinning rainbow
wheel i'm just like trying to stutter to
the next webpage it's really hard to i
think even absorb as a kid you felt
you felt like the weird kid in class the
outsider in class did you
yes and i think i i still feel that way
you still feel that oh all the time
did you see yourself on the red carpet
at the football team where people were
you walking around they go it's amanda
gorman right here you still feel that
way yes i think there's like a little
bit of that imposter syndrome because
i'm such a nerd such a geek can be so
gangly and i think when i was growing up
you know i wasn't just kind of a really
brainy kid i was a really black kid i
was a really skinny kid i was really
small kid and also a kid whose voice was
kind of distorted by a speech impediment
so all of these things kind of made me
feel as othered or too different you
might say and so yeah it really made me
feel sometimes on the outside looking in
and i think
nowadays with more age behind me i look
back at it and i am so grateful for that
experience because all the things that
make me different make me who i am and
they make me great so starting from that
where does your confidence come from
today i think my confidence wasn't
necessarily something that i taught
myself but something that was modeled
for me i was raised by a single mother
and i think the way in which she would
walk through the space and kind of hold
herself as a black woman that was a
great type of kind of
symbol for me to look at and go ah this
is how i can continue in this world
gorman's walk through the world of
literature is really more like a sprint
that
is the promise to glade the hill we
climb if only we dare it her book the
hill we climb an inaugural poem for the
country became the first book of poetry
to debut at number one on usa today's
best-selling books list she says her new
book will serve as a record of the
baggage and the blessings we've carried
through this pandemic every cough seemed
catastrophe every person a potential
peril we mapped each sneeze in sniffle i
thought that's so true i remember
somebody sneezing come here what was
that
certain the virus we had run away from
was now running through us
what made you write that
it was part of me trying to
document i think the social emotional
reality of what a pandemic is i can give
you facts it can give you numbers i can
give you deaths but when you're walking
through life
afraid to breathe afraid to be close and
proximate to people i think that does
something to the body and to the soul
there's no power like home we are sick
of home homesick the mask around our ear
hung itself into the year
i'm so honored that you like my my word
player i do let's talk about your
wordplay yes and your process with that
i think i really wanted to take certain
phrases and turn them on their heads not
necessarily to kind of feel smart and
pat myself on the back but when you look
at it in many ways we're really lacking
language around how to grieve how to be
at lost i wanted to create rhetoric that
could more accurately represent our
experience what is your process when you
start to write a poem is there a certain
thing
wow i'm trying to think of my process
and it's really messy and it can look
like different things and i think with
the moments of turns of phrase in the
book it was less so me at my desk trying
to write puns but more so me
walking through the world walking down
the street seeing signs and really
listening to people and hearing the
words that we use
to each other about each other writing
poems put gorman on the map and in
murals too from her hometown in los
angeles to washington d.c the place
where she plans to one day attend an
inauguration of her own you sit here
today as a 23 year old young woman but
as a young girl at 11 you said i i
intend to run for president in 2036.
i'm thinking at 11 i might have been
still playing with barbie i was
certainly doing puzzles
um well you should know five years ago i
said i wanted to be the inaugural poet
and now we're here so you said that you
said that five years five years ago i
think
there's um there's a type of spirit in
me which feels if i'm not going to dream
a dream for myself who was going to if
not now one if not here where if not me
who and so it's kind of that questioning
of both myself and the world that gives
me these ideas of how are the ways that
i can continue to make change all right
let's do three fun facts about amanda
that only amanda knows that we don't go
um
one i am a huge star trek fan
two
i can walk on my hands you can yes i can
in three
i have kind of a fear of feet i don't
like looking at people's feet
really
no like put your shoes back on thank you
very much that's very funny when i think
about you i think that
i admire and i celebrate your confidence
but i also read that you said i'm still
trying to figure out who amanda gorman
is
how does one figure out who they are
that's great especially if they're you
yes yes i remember uh this was several
years ago um and i saw kind of a sign as
i was walking kind of down a hallway
that was uh life isn't about finding
yourself it's about creating yourself
and so if i throw away this idea that
there's going to be a kind of
singular destination in which i arrive
at myself but rather that it's more so
of a journey it's more so of a climb
then that's the type of voyage that i
can kind of invest myself in
amanda gorman a rock star i said to her
who are your friends do you have friends
and she goes yeah she has a very solid
friend group but she admits she is the
nerd of the group and she has many a
variety of friends small but very secure
she has a twin sister i didn't know she
had a twin gabrielle shout out to
gabrielle who's a filmmaker she said for
fun she reads a book three times if she
likes it first to read it second to take
it in to see what she can learn from it
and third to see if there's a way that
she could rewrite it better and when she
was a little kid
because she still says she's a nerd she
used to read the thesaurus because she
has a speech impediment when she was
younger where she couldn't say ours so
she read that book to come up with
different words
so she's there i said i think my
vocabulary is good but your vocabulary
is off the charts and the way that she
puts the words together it's just a
delightful afternoon to spend with her
she's a national treasure i i just like
when i asked you about her friends it's
like because i want i want all of us
collectively to protect her yes
exactly you all feel that exactly she is
leading the way keep going amanda that's
right going